the boss of VP believes $100 a barrel
for oil is a real possibility and as
warmth at the current cost a few is
proving to be expensive for large
emerging economies I caught up with Bob
Dudley bp's chief executive at the
oneworld young world summit at the hague
and i began by asking him whether fossil
fuels will continue to be a big part of
the world's energy landscape I don't
like the term fossil fuels because it's
such a big spectrum from clean burning
natural gas make sure it doesn't leak
and then there's oil and then there's
coal over here so the term fossil fuel I
think simplifies something about it more
than it should so today 80% of the world
is still this basket of fuels I think
you have to separate out electric power
with transportation fuels because
electric power electricity I mean that's
where coal and natural gas should be the
primary and I hope natural gas the
primary one transportation is different
a little bundle of dense hydrocarbon
that's stable drives a lot of
transportation system combined that more
efficiently with electrification of
vehicles I think that's the future
you're investing very heavily an
electric car charging right now when you
expect to see return on that investment
well we just purchased the largest
vehicle charging company in the UK we'll
put it on our four courts and and around
the cities as well I think it's going to
be a combination of when the cars are
coming to the market there's still not
that many electric vehicles and they'll
probably be more more in the city than
the country side itself with long
distances but their investments it's
like exploration or other things that we
do there that's a risk can't say for
sure but we think is the uptake comes
with people using the cars combining it
probably with our retail sites and
selling other things like coffee and
clothes which is happening I think it's
all got to be part of a system of
providing energy did you know that more
people come into BP stations now and
don't buy fuel than do because of the
convenience the shopping the coffee
I mean it's it'll be a different model
obviously there's been a big drop in
investment by the global oil industry
since 2014 does that mean that we're
looking at a pinch point in the future
where supply will necessarily not be
able to meet demand it could I don't I
don't know well I take a little comfort
now because when the prices were very
high the cost of investment was very
high and what's happened is efficiencies
been driven in cost reductions
everywhere in the energy chain so you
could do a lot more today with a dollar
of investment than we certainly could
five years ago so but at some point
demand continues to grow for all forms
of energy it could catch up and I it's
not good for the world to have the kind
of oil prices we have today they're too
high that's too high they're too high
I think there's a fair way which is a
price of oil between 1565 say today that
allows production countries that produce
to have a fair price and stable and
consuming countries to purchase it where
we are today for example it's the
highest prices ever in the history of
India because of not only oil plus the
currency movements this is not helpful
to some consuming countries does not
mean the world has to brace itself a
$100 oil in the near future it's
possible but I think equally we could
see it drop down another 10 15 dollars a
barrel depending on and certain things
that happens I think if if exemptions
were given on the sanctions you could
see an immediate drop in the price of
oil if they tightened up you can see it
go up Venezuela is defying economic
gravity there's uncertainty there and
then in the u.s. this place called the
Permian is very bottlenecked up and at
some point those pipelines next year
will start flowing and that'll bring
more supplies to the market and what
about the relationship that Saudi Arabia
has with the outside world I mean it
seemed as though the kingdom was opening
itself up this row over khashoggi the
journalist appears to be turning the
international community against Saudi
Arabia would you be concerned if Saudi
Arabia started to retaliate against some
of the noise that's coming their way by
cutting
I think I mean experience says that
Saudi Arabia's has been very responsible
country it that I actually don't see
them using energy as a weapon I know
they worry about having enough
production for growing populations to
make sure they don't get blamed for not
having enough energy so it doesn't feel
in character for that a lot of people
are quite cynical about big business so
do you have a challenge in convincing
ordinary people that be peers of a
willing partner a good partner in this
fight rather than an adversary I think I
think big business has a really
misfortunate reputation right now I mean
big business is really collections of
people who have assets and make
investments it is people who provide a
lot of taxes into the system provide a
lot of pensions in the system people
forget that I think and then so what do
we do in the communities where we
operate are all around the world we're
partners with the communities we support
all kinds of programs outside of what we
do education health sports culture I
think I think people don't see that our
employees know it and they love what we
do we'll keep doing that but I just hope
people don't vilify business because
it's actually the engines of economies
around the world and I think it's I
think it's wrong and misguided although
it's easy to paint and label like fossil
fuels fossil fuels is so complex I think
companies are very different I'm very
proud of what we do would be P all
around the world